rocketskates our electric escapes we
want to make it so that you become your
transportation and so ultimately what
we're shooting for is something that you
can wear all day and never take off you
can wear pretty much any shoe with the
skates you can turn on either one first
it doesn't really matter which what's
there on then you press your control
skate down into the ground as a kind of
safety once you roll the motors kick in
at somewhere around one or two miles an
hour
we have hub motors one in each of the
larger wheels on the backs we have
lithium ion batteries and those give the
motors power they have bluetooth on them
so they connect to your phone and we
have an app that allows you to control
the performance watch what your friends
are doing the skates are very inspired
by automotive sources the launches
Stratos from long ago these wheels are
designed with that car in mind
the last Kickstarter we did we asked for
I think it was 50,000 and we ended up
with 550 which was just outrageous we've
sold a little over a thousand skates so
far and the prices range from 500 to 700
dollars it just takes a long time to get
to a product that people can actually
use you can just let them go and they
can take off with it